きよサッカーでこけたいっ
大丈夫コケた分だけ強くなれるさ
あ
どうぞ
黒の犬種ですそれでちょっといつ買ったか覚えてないんですけど結構昔
店
買ったんですよソードアートオンラインのでながすごいベアというか全然手に入らなく
てようやくさっき届いたってやつなんですけどそれは今回あげたいと思います
美尻コレクションうわあああっああいいと思った6て5キロで方設けじゃないでしょう
ねちょっと濃いんですけどこれで1本の剣ですよ中に入ってるのがいけますよ
リリーセレクション
きましたこちらですオーダードンラインハイフレットえっドリーとわいすぺしゃわー
でしょそう切りたがソードアートオンラインで疲れた件でございますネザー
15万円で
ああいやあもう相当遊ん内の規律といえばもう男の憧れだと思うんですよあんな中二病
でちょっとこの芸だ残すでちょっとテンション上がってますからねそれグレーもかっこ
いいんですよ
そんな彼がアジア家の中で使うけんの最高クラスのできな奴がようやくというかという
わけでございます
いたしますね6.5キロでつかんでヤバ
ほとんど9分以内ぐらいなんですけど結構昔に買ったんですよねアマゾンの値段見たら
15番で書いてあって
a 5埋まりそうだなかったのって9分だったんですけどもいやーちょっと風を忘れた
頃に届きましたねさすが外でいきましょう
俺この幻の開閉のために今日キリトの発行するからねちょっと本当に期待が膨らんで
おります
スターバーストレーン
箱も傷つけたくないけど多分得ることも知ってることがないんで
中村区で言って dba コレクション a house
天燈
優勝うわぁ
明日だ
あっはい
ポッ
ん
えっこはぁはぁん
は
言えこんなことしたくないですよほんとん演出のためにあってからねって想像透明なに
ねまずでいいですよ見たことない人氣人と脚何のイチャイチャ2人のそのラブラブ夫婦
のカップルか守りめっちゃ好きで
で買えば旦那物等により好きなんですよねそうやって守られてた俺の eacd た
無事のようだ
味が入ってますねさっそく見てみましょうかほい war
なんかがトランクみたいになってるおちゃんでこのレベルある
やすいで
ああ
最悪だ
アフターでも売らないからいいや z やらないし一生大事にするんですけど
さあお前だけは許さないですがそういうわけでおもちゃの剣が入ってると思いません
このデザインかっこよすぎでしょこれねまず15万円はちょっとおもちゃのレベルを
超えてるんで俺を方は同県だと思ってます
さっそく開けてみようと思います
うわぁ品超する伊織の部分めちゃくちゃ欲しくて買ったと思うんだよ
いきます
はぁ
4 f
言葉オスなるわー
[音楽]
ガッコいいえするいたしますねー
いやー2
さあ本あーばって思う生え
lc データベース詰まってい
総合考慮多すぎてびっくりしたんだけどあとなんか付属品が凄いねこれなんだろう電池
やと usb も入ってるんですけど
鍵が入ってんだけど何のためのいや中身はほんとこれだけですねやってなってるんです
よ
紅葉すぎるんですけど
[音楽]
か
ka これが15万円ぬーんだよ
なザイロ政策はついてんだ機動歩兵たな場所に行けて便利配当します電源がオンになる
と緑運転等
はいっ
システムこ&
10年の
はいというわけで充電が完了しましたこれで多分電源つければいくはずだと思います
木戸白 l 4データー
ござい
なんか今ファ
なんか
入ってるホラー
ホラー
こりゃあホラーんやってる見てこれ完全に勝ってもこれが今何か
止まった
[音楽]
光っている
えっ
レッツ
[音楽]
ん
関数までかっこいいいい
すごい
[音楽]
マッハケールとひかるー
うぇっ
かっこよすぎ
あっはぁああ俺がキリトだっ
キターねやれ危うく開くになるとこだったぜ
すごい強モーションに上げて光るんですね
で音もちゃんとなってるんだよ
[音楽]
えっ何
なんかいい
あの王楽が
[音楽]
[拍手]
駄文
うわぁ
ザーッ
いい
タマ姉
voodoo
スターバーストストリーム
のマイクも付いてるらしいんですよマイクに合わせてこういうのが演出だったりスター
バーストストリームをする時の音楽が流れるみたいな素です
カッケーす女医さんのアプリ使われる基本的に出来る事はこんくらい
ただもうなんてかっこいい戦でもの光り方がやばいいや魚残存ない好きな人もいます
たまんない犬でしょこんなの
方や梅雨ようなんだねああ
i 時で ng データ買ってみただけなんですけどもいやー15マイムの価値は
ああ
あるかはわかりませんがそこは人次第ですただまずでかっこいいしたの私件次いでの
ヤバイってよねさんちょっとファンにはたまらない逸品かなと思いました
[音楽]
voodoo
あった
[音楽]